Holi is a festival of colors. Colors
and colors everywhere. You must have heard in childhood that Holi
is such a festival that you say do
good instead of bad, but
why don't we apply it
in our lives? We carry the burden of negative virus in our lives.  There are
issues going on and we do
n't end them. If we have a
problem with a friend or a problem with someone the day before yesterday,
we don't even go and discuss with him. It doesn't
happen like this, we decide on this Holi
only, children.  That we will remove all the
negative vibes in our mind regarding
any topic of day after tomorrow and
start a new life again for a happy life and have a
happy Holi and like gas bye bye.
[music]